hallo zusammen schönen guten Abend wir
sind live mit ZDF heute live Donald
Trump und der Sturm auf das Kapitol
wollte er wirklich am 6 Januar 2021 mit
allen Mitteln an der Macht bleiben damit
beschäftigt sich aktuell einen
Untersuchungsausschuss und der trifft
sich heute wahrscheinlich zum letzten
Mal vor den anstehenden Zwischenwahlen
im November hier sehen wir jetzt Bilder
dieses Ausschusses der gerade aktuell
Takt und wir hören auch kurz rein was
der Vorsitzende des
Untersuchungsausschusses Benny Thompson
zu Beginn der Sitzung gesagt hat er hat
wirklich deutliche Worte gefunden
nach der Wahl 2020 vor hatte ist etwas
was kein Präsident zuvor in unserem Land
getan hat er hat einen erschütternden
Verrat an seinem Eid begangen indem er
einen Plan unternahmen der sich zu einem
Angriff auf eine Säule unserer
Demokratie ausweitete es ist immer noch
schwer zu glauben
über die Rolle von Trump
Rechtsextremisten und Staatsfeinden in
den USA wollen wir heute sprechen und
wir wollen darüber sprechen in welche
Richtung sich das Land verändert wir
reden mit unserem usa-korrespondenten el
Mathe Wissen der nicht nur meine Fragen
gerne beantwortet sondern auch ihre und
eure deshalb gerne einfach in die Chat
schreiben oder eine E-Mail schicken wir
legen gleich los vorher noch kurz
Christian Rufus mit einem Überblick über
die Ereignisse
eine Gefahr für die Demokratie sind
Donald Trump und seine Anhänger das ist
die Botschaft die vom Ausschuss bleiben
wird viele von ihnen waren zu allem
bereit an diesem sechsten januar vor
fast zwei Jahren
was immer nötig ist wir sind bereit für
diese Sache zu sterben mittendrin der
Filmemacher Nick quested öffentlich soll
er der erste von mehr als 1.000 Zeugen
sein die der U-Ausschuss befragt die
Gitter fielen und die Menschen fluteten
hinein wie Wasser dass sich überall
hinausbreitet
in den acht Anhörungen bisher wird
schnell klar Donald Trump hat Gewalt
bewusst in Kauf genommen um sich an der
Macht zu halten Prominente wie
überraschende Zeugen sollten das belegen
kesse die Hutchinson etwa damals 25
rechte Hand von Trumps Stabschef
Trump sagte sowas wie es ist mir
scheißegal dass sie Waffen haben sie
sind ja nicht gegen mich gerichtet baut
die Metalldetektoren ab lasst meine
Leute rein dass sie zum Capitol
marschieren dürfen
trotz all dem stellen sich die
Republikaner dem Ausschuss von Anfang an
in den Weg so gilt die Bühne auch immer
wieder trump-kritikerin Liz Jamie die
ihrer Partei den Spiegel vorher hält
ich sage zu meinen republikanischen
Kollegen die das Verteidigen was nicht
zu verteidigen ist irgendwann ist Donald
Trump weg aber eure Ehrlosigkeit wird
bleiben
und dann immer wieder die Lüge von der
gestohlenen Wahl Trumps engster Kreis
sagt aus selbst sie hätten schnell
Abstand von seinen kruden Fantasien
genommen
wurde ich sagte dem Präsidenten das ist
Bullshit
und so sah es auch Trumps Tochter
ich respektiere Justizminister Bar also
akzeptierte ich was er sagte
dazu lädt der Ausschuss zuletzt auch
Jenny Thomas vor die Frau eines Richters
am Supreme chord soll den Staatschef des
Weißen Hauses kurz nach der Wahl
kontaktiert haben und Trump doch noch
zum Sieger zu erklären aber was bleibt
nun von all dem denn der Ausschuss ist
kein Gericht
und das ist ein wichtiger Unterschied
zwischen dem Ausschuss und der Rolle des
Justizministeriums der Ausschuss kann
keine Strafverfolgung einleiten sie
können niemanden verurteilen was auch
immer Sie herausfinden
ob und wann genau das Komitee diesen
Gang zum Justizministerium wagt das ist
allerdings noch offen
hallo Elmar grüß Dich
hallo nach Deutschland
Emma du hast nicht nur damals den 6
Januar hautnah miterlebt und bis selbst
in Bedrängnis geraten was auch diesen
Untersuchungsausschuss von Anfang an
verfolgt der läuft jetzt seit einer
Stunde worum geht es heute genau was
konntest du bisher hören
ja ich will mal ein bisschen darlegen
was in der ersten Stunde besprochen
wurde man will einmal darstellen dass
das was am 6 Januar da passiert ist
wirklich ein langer Plan war von langer
Hand geplant Donald Trump in jeden
Schritt involviert sei es nun direkt
oder indirekt und der Ausschuss hat
vorhin sich ein bisschen aufgeteilt
einzelne Schritte mal dargestellt ich
will das mal wiedergeben man hat
begonnen chronologisch mit der
wahlnachts im November 2020 in jener
Nacht hat Donald Trump dann schon
während noch Stimmen ausgezählt war
wurden sich vor die Presse gestellt und
hat behauptet dass er die Wahl gewonnen
hätte und hat auch behauptet die Wahl
sei gestohlen worden und dass man
bitteschön sofort das nachzählen oder
das Zählen der Stimmen einstellen sollte
allein das wäre schon eine Straftat weil
das Einstellen vom Zellen der Stimmen
ist eben nach amerikanischem Recht eine
Straftat dass er das nicht einfach mal
so spontan gemacht hat nach der
Ausschuss vorhin mit einigen E-Mails und
Aussagen auch sehr eindrucksvoll belegt
offenbar war schon Wochen vorher aber
insbesondere auch im Oktober also einige
Tage vor der Wahl intern bei Donald
Trump mehreren gesagt worden dass
tatsächlich eher eine Siegesrede halten
würde egal wie die Wahl ausgehen würde
und ob das Ergebnis schon da ist und
dass er genau das sagen würde eben ich
habe die Wahl gewonnen und man soll
bitte sofort das Auszählen der Stimmen
einstellen davon wussten seine Berater
Steve bennen und auch Roger Stone das
sind Personen die aus dem
rechtsextremistischen Feld kommen und
die Kontakte zu rechtsextremistischen
Gruppen unterhalten als zweites hat man
dann auch dargestellt dass in den Wochen
und Monaten danach Donald Trump sehr
wohl wusste dass er die Wahl verloren
hat weil er selber wiederholt gesagt hat
hinter verschlossenen Türen gegenüber
Beratern weil er selber beispielsweise
auch Anweisungen gegeben hat die darauf
hin oder beweisen sogar dass er damit
rechnete dass er ab dem 20 Januar eben
nicht mehr im Amt sein würde er hat dann
weiter drittens ganz offenbar eben
versucht
die Berater zu ignorieren die ihm alle
gesagt haben er sollte doch jetzt
endlich mal seine Niederlage eingestehen
unter diesen Beratern waren
beispielsweise sein eigener
Rechtsberater im Weißen Haus der
Justitia gewissermaßen sein eigener
Justizminister auch sein eigener
Außenminister alle ignoriert stattdessen
hat er und das ist der nächste Punkt
Punkt 4 diese Lüge von der angeblich
gestohlenen Wahl öffentlich immer weiter
verbreitet und seine Anhänger damit
aufgestachelt das kann man an Videos
sehen an reden die er gehalten hat an
Auftritten die er gehabt hat in dieser
Zeit wo er genau das getan hat und er
hat dann Punkt 5 tatsächlich auch in
diesen Wochen versucht Wahlbeamte in
Bundesstaaten einzuschüchtern er hat sie
angerufen bis zum innen von Georgia
hinauf oder auch von hohen Beratern bzw
Beamten in diesen Bundesstaaten dass er
ihnen gesagt hat sie sollten doch jetzt
bitte mal die notwendigen Stimmen finden
damit er im Amt bleiben könnte er hat
sie also aufgefordert im Grunde genommen
illegalerweise eine Wahl für ungültig zu
erklären auch das sehr eindrucksvoll
belegt und dann eben am Vorabend des 6
Januar hat er ganz offenbar schon im
Vorfeld Tage vorher mit seinen Beratern
aus diesem rechtsextremen Spektrum Roger
Stone und Steve Bannon sehr klar gemacht
was er wollte was an diesem sechsten
Januar passiert das ist das was wir
bisher zu hören bekommen haben und was
jetzt noch kommt das wissen wir weil
einiges davon schon vorher rausgedrungen
ist dass man anhand von E-Mails
Kommunikation des Secret Service also
der Regierungsbehörde die für den Schutz
des Präsidenten verantwortlich ist dass
man aus dieser Kommunikation
beweisen kann dass Donald Camp am 6
Januar wusste dass bewaffnete gekommen
waren nach Washington er wusste dass sie
vor seiner Veranstaltung außerhalb
dieser Metalldetektoren warteten und
bewaffnet waren er wusste zum Zeitpunkt
des Endes seiner Rede am Weißen Haus das
tatsächlich schon Gewalt ausgeübt wurde
am Kapitol und der forderte dann
tatsächlich mit dem Auto dorthin
gefahren zu werden zu seinen Anhängern
er hätte also Öl ins Feuer gießen können
und dann weiß aus der Kommunikation dass
der Secret Service diesen Befehl
verweigert hat regelrecht verweigert hat
mit der Begründung man könne seine
Sicherheit nicht gewährleisten Donald
Trump war darüber stinksauer auch das
wissen wir aus mehreren Aussagen das
werden wir im Verlauf der nächsten
Stunde wahrscheinlich detailliert noch
einmal belegt bekommen und dann muss das
Komitee muss der Ausschuss tatsächlich
entscheiden ob er abstimmt darüber dass
man wegen möglicher Straftaten das
Justizministerium
erfordert Anklage gegen Donald Trump zu
erheben zum Beispiel weil er eben
versucht hat den normalen Wahlprozess zu
untergraben zu unterminieren das wäre
ein bundesverbrechen und er könnte dafür
angeklagt werden und wenn diese
Erkenntnisse sich bewahrheiten dann hat
Donald Trump ja auch wissentlich und
willentlich Menschenleben gefährdet dazu
stellt sich eine Frage an von
Caterpillar hallo ZDF ist das dann nicht
Hochverrat was Trump hier getan hat und
welche Strafe kann er dafür bekommen
also politisch glauben einige dass man
das als Hochverrat bezeichnen kann
rechtlich ist das nicht so einfach denn
Hochverrat nach amerikanischem Recht
kann nur in Zeiten des Krieges
tatsächlich verübt werden jedenfalls in
dem Sinne wie viele das meinen darüber
kann man politisch streiten aber
rechtlich wäre das schwer nachzuweisen
aber man kann tatsächlich mehrere
Straftaten möglicherweise nachweisen die
eine wäre zu versuchen den Wahlprozess
und das Wahlergebnis zu verhindern das
zweite wäre Beamte
einzuschüchtern also sie unter Druck zu
setzen und zu erpressen zu fordern
tatsächlich diese Wahl für ungültig zu
erklären auch das wäre ein
bundesvergehen des Weiteren wäre es eben
auch ein Vergehen wenn er
Rechtsextremisten wenn der Gewalttäter
direkt oder indirekt aufgefordert hätten
eben einen Umsturz versucht zu wagen
danach sieht alles aus an jedem 6 Januar
dafür gibt es auch den ein oder anderen
Beleg also auch das eine Straftat die
justiziabel andere auch gegen Donald
Trump und das letzte oder nicht das
letzte aber auch noch eine wichtige über
die der Untersuchungsausschuss beraten
wird wäre eine Straftat dass er versucht
hat seine Anhänger zu betrügen auch das
ist eine Geschichte die spannend ist
denn in den Monaten seit der verlorenen
Wahl bis zum 6 januar und weit darüber
hinaus eigentlich bis heute verbreitet
er ja die Lüge von der angeblich
gestohlenen Wahl und sammelt damit Geld
in jenen ersten Monaten immer mit dem
Hinweis dass das dazu dient dann eben
die Klagen vor Gericht er hat ja über 60
klagen angestrengt fast alle sind
komplett abgewiesen worden übrigens dass
er immer diesen Hinweis hatte das Geld
geht dann eben in diesen
verteidigungsfonds und dieses Geld ist
stattdessen in seinen political action
comedy gewandert sprich in seine
Kriegskasse für mögliche künftige
Wahlkämpfe und das wäre Betrug an seinen
eigenen Anhängern auch das könnte eine
Straftat sein und auch darüber muss der
Untersuchungsausschuss entscheiden ob er
das weiter reicht ans Justizministerium
und damit wäre auch schon die Frage von
Ralf Feddersen beantwortet der eben
gefragt hat inwieweit die Kenntnis von
Trump über die
capitolerstörung den Tatbestand des
Hochverrats erfüllen würde
wir schauen mal weiter denn dieser
Ausschuss der gerade läuft ist ja nun
nicht das einzige Gremium dass ich
gerade mit Donald Trump befassen muss
Christian Volk gibt uns da einen
Überblick
Ex-Präsident Trump kämpft juristisch
derzeit an vielen Fronten aufgearbeitet
im us-nachrichten Fernsehen insgesamt 17
Fälle einer davon ein möglicher Verstoß
gegen das spionagegesetz Anfang August
beschlagnahmte das FBI in seinem Anwesen
in Florida streng geheime Dokumente aus
seiner Amtszeit laut Medienbericht hatte
Trump einen Mitarbeiter zuvor
kistenweise Material umräumen lassen um
eine Rückgabe zu vereiteln es drohen
mehrere Jahre Gefängnis eine Autorin
möchte ihn außerdem wegen Vergewaltigung
vor Gericht bringen Mitte der 90er-Jahre
sei Trump in einem Kaufhaus übergriffig
geworden so ihr Vorwurf im Bundesstaat
New York läuft bereits ein
Zivilverfahren wegen Betrugs gegen Trump
seine Kinder und seine Firma Kern der
Klage Trump habe regelmäßig über den
Wert seines Besitzes gelogen er blähte
ihn auf um an günstige Kredite zu kommen
hier droht eine Millionen Geldstrafe und
in einem weiteren Metall werfen die
Behörden Trumps Unternehmen vor über
Jahre systematisch Steuern hinterzogen
zu haben der Ex-Präsident dementiert all
diese Vorwürfe er spricht immer wieder
von einer Hexenjagd
also es gibt Politikerinnen und
Politiker da hat schon viel weniger in
die politische Bedeutungslosigkeit
geführt warum hat man bei Donald Trump
immer das Gefühl dass er da irgendwie
mit durchkommt
ja ich glaube das hat zwei Gründe das
eine ist tatsächlich dass er mit seinen
Anwälten und er hat ja Geld genug auch
weil er seinen Anhänger eine Menge Geld
abgenommen hat durch Spenden Geld genug
um eben Anwälte zu engagieren die es
schaffen diese Verfahren immer und immer
und immer weiter hinauszuziehen dann
geht es in die nächste Instanz dann wird
wieder irgendein anderer Grund gefunden
aber man hat den Eindruck dass sich die
Schlinge doch jetzt ein Stück weit
zuzieht weil eben die Gerichte auch
nicht mehr bereit sind das einfach so
immer zu akzeptieren Beispiele in diesem
möglichen Vergewaltigungsfall aus den
90er Jahren soll Donald Trump in der
kommenden Woche Aussagen auch das hat er
versucht mit allen Mitteln zu verhindern
aber ein Gericht hat eben jetzt
entschieden nein er muss am 19 Oktober
dort eben Aussagen und das bürgt dann
für ihn immer die Gefahr dass meine als
also dass er etwas sagt was er hinterher
was sich als Lüge herausstellt und dafür
kann er belangt werden das ist also ein
Grund das Anwälte immer die Dinge
herauszögern können und das andere
ja das ist im Grunde noch viel
beunruhigender das ist eben auch
vielleicht Richter gibt in den USA die
er selber berufen hat als er noch
Präsident war die jetzt den Amt und
Würden sind und ihm aus politisch
ideologischen Gründen in irgendeiner
Weise helfen und da wird von den
Kritikern von den politischen Gegnern
von Donald Trump immer das Beispiel
jener Richterin angeführt die gerade die
Federführung hat bei dem Fall um die
Dokumente in malago eine Richterin die
einst von ihm berufen wurde und die ganz
offenbar da sind sich Rechtsexperten in
den USA einig weit über das hinaus was
sie darf und was im Gesetz wirklich zu
finden ist
Entscheidungen fällt die tatsächlich
Donald Trump helfen das Verfahren
herauszuzögern oder möglicherweise auch
eine letztlich eine Strafe zu verhindern
also ein Gerichtsprozess und dann eine
Strafe zu verhindern ich glaube das sind
aber alles nur verzögerungstaktiken weil
mittlerweile eben genügend Fälle da sind
wo sich die Schlinge zuzieht eben auch
übrigens in dem Fall mit den Dokumenten
in malago denn eben durch diesen einen
Zeugen der ganz offenbar diese Kisten
auch weggetragen hat in den persönlichen
Bereich im Golfclub von Donald Trump in
malago auf seine Anweisung hin so
jedenfalls hat er offenbar ausgesagt das
belegt dass Donald Trump hier Justiz
Behinderung begangen haben könnte denn
wenige Tage vorher war bei ihm die
Aufforderung eingegangen eben all diese
Unterlagen herauszugeben und danach hat
er die Anweisung erteilt diese Kartons
in seinen Privatbereich zu bringen das
ist eine eine Straftat wenn das
nachweisbar wäre für die er auch mit
mehreren Jahren Gefängnis rechnen müsste
lass uns noch mal zu dem
Untersuchungsausschuss zurückkommen der
aktuell läuft da hat Noah eine Frage hat
dieser Ausschuss Auswirkungen auf die
kommenden Wahlen vielleicht kannst Du
erklären warum das so wichtig ist und
wie das miteinander zusammenhängt
ja das eine ist natürlich die große
Frage inwieweit Donald Trump ist gelingt
bei seinen Anhängern sich als verfolgte
Unschuld darzustellen und zu sagen da
sind die politischen Gegner darauf aus
ihm zu schaden also eine Hexenjagd
durchzuführen und das könnte seine
Anhänger Beuern und das tut es auch wir
waren im Land unterwegs ganz offenbar
Anhänger die ihm das Abnehmen aber auf
der anderen Seite gibt es auch eine
ganze Menge Menschen in den USA die doch
nicht nur wegen dieses Falles sondern
auch wegen der dokumentengeschichte in
Mara Lago und anderen Punkten das Gefühl
bekommen der darf eigentlich nicht
wieder politisch irgendein Amt haben
weil er immer nur auf seinen eigenen
Vorteil bedacht ist und nicht auf die
Interessen des Landes schaut und die
Menschen die das Denken die gehören
nicht nur der Demokratischen Partei an
das sind auch unabhängige Wähler das
sind republikanische Wähler so und jetzt
gibt es die Zwischenwahlen im November 8
November und da entscheidet sich sowohl
ob die Mehrheitsverhältnisse in
Washington bleiben wie sie sind also ob
beide kann man amerikanischen Kongresses
eine demokratische Mehrheit haben das
könnte am Ende sehr knapp sein es könnte
in Richtung Republikaner wechseln und es
entscheidet sich auch ob auf den
verschiedenen Ebenen in den
Bundesstaaten gouverneursämter
Innenminister Justizminister Ämter aber
auch die jeweiligen Abgeordnete in den
Parlamenten ob da eben Anhänger von
Donald Trump in Amt und Würden kommen
Trump piston und einige von denen um
nicht zu sagen sogar viele ich habe hier
mal eine Zahl von 87 Kandidaten die
antreten für
Ämter mit denen man Einfluss ausüben
könnte auf künftige Wahlergebnisse
beispielsweise die Innenminister in den
jeweiligen Bundesstaaten die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass die Regeln
eingehalten werden also von diesen 87
Kandidaten für solche Ämter sind 53
Kandidaten die ja der wahllüge anhängen
die also auch verbreiten dass Donald
Trump um seine Wahl betrogen wurde und
Joe Biden gar nicht der legitime
Präsident ist und es gibt einem vor
einem Vorgeschmack darauf warum diese
Wahl im November so wichtig ist und
deswegen ist auch diese Anhörung heute
so wichtig weil es ist der große und
letzte Versuch von diesem Ausschuss noch
einmal Wirkung zu entfalten in der
Öffentlichkeit um klar zu machen was
hier auf dem Spiel steht ist Jenny hat
vorhin gesagt es ist die Demokratie die
in diesem Land auf dem Spiel steht das
heißt dass die Anhänger von Trump
versuchen in die Ämter zu kommen um das
System quasi von innen auszuhüllen und
zu zu zerstören zu zu stören zumindest
die Frage ist ja aber warum wird dieser
Abschlussbericht des
Untersuchungsausschusses warum wird er
erst nach den Wahlen veröffentlicht
ja es hängt wahrscheinlich auch allein
schon mit diesem riesen Volumen an
Beweisen zusammen 1,5 Millionen E-Mails
und andere Kommunikation von Secret
Service aus den Monaten nach der Wahl
und über den 6 Januar hinweg das muss
alles noch zu Ende ausgewertet werden um
diesen Fall eben zwingend zu machen und
vor allen Dingen wenn es eine Abstimmung
dann im Kongress geben sollte um
Straftaten an das Justizministerium
weiterzugeben und und Anklage zu fordern
mehr kann der Kongress nicht tun dann
müssen die Beweise natürlich Hieb und
Stich fest sein jetzt gibt es ein
Problem damit dieser Abschlussbericht
muss möglichst schnell fertig werden
weil am 8 November eben die
Zwischenwahlen die Kongresswahlen sind
und der neu gewählte Kongress von diesen
Wahlen der tritt dann im Januar zusammen
und wenn da die Mehrheiten wechselt oder
gewechselt sind besser gesagt also wenn
die Republikaner dann im
Abgeordnetenhaus vielleicht auch im
Senat die Mehrheit haben dann könnten
sie nicht nicht nur die Arbeit des
Untersuchungsausschusses stoppen also
sprich der Bericht würde dann nie
veröffentlicht man würde im Gegenteil
einen neuen Untersuchungsausschuss und
das wäre die Konsequenz das haben
Republikaner schon angekündigt einen
Untersuchungsausschuss Starten der sich
gegen Joe Biden richtet wo man
angeblichen Wahlbetrug untersuchen will
aber eben auch andere Verbindungen von
Joe Biden über seinen Sohn Handarbeiten
in irgendwelche kriminellen
Machenschaften nachweisen will also da
haben die Republikaner angekündigt dass
wenn Sie die Mehrheiten gewinnen sie den
Spieß umdrehen wollen und Joe Biden den
Präsidenten ins Visier nehmen wollen
Donald Trump hat ja noch nicht offiziell
gesagt dass er wieder als
Präsidentschaftskandidat antreten will
aber er lässt es ja immer mal wieder
durchblicken und dazu hat Jan plaum eine
Frage er möchte wissen ob Trump trotz
aller Verfahren und Vorwürfe an der
nächsten Wahl überhaupt teilnehmen kann
als Kandidat
also nach jetzigen Stand Kanadas es gilt
sogar in den USA selbst wenn man eines
schweren Versprecher Verbrechens einer
Straftat auf Bundesebene überführt wurde
also eine phänomie schwere Straftat
begangen hat und dafür verurteilt würde
könnte man noch antreten für eine Wahl
und könnte Präsident werden also das
hindert ein nicht er könnte nicht mehr
selber wählen wenn er verurteilt würde
aber er könnte nach wie vor gewählt
werden und manche Beobachter glauben
dass Donald Trump ist darauf anlegt
möglicherweise die Flucht nach vorne
anzutreten als Präsidentschaftskandidat
um dann wenn er als Präsident da ist
sich selber vielleicht möglicherweise
dann zu begnadigen oder ähnliches also
viele glauben nichts ist ausgeschlossen
aber wir waren Stück auch im Land
unterwegs für eine Dokumentation zur
Wahl wir waren in Michigan wir waren in
North Carolina aber ganz besonders
letzte Woche auch in Arizona und da
haben wir Trump Anhänger getroffen die
so überzeugt davon sind dass er
eigentlich noch der Präsident ist und
auch bereit sind ihn zu unterstützen
möglicherweise auch mit Waffen Gewalt
vielleicht können wir uns die Bilder mal
anschauen wir waren bei den aufkeepers
das ist eine von diesen extremistischen
Gruppierungen die Donald Trump auch am 6
Januar unterstützt haben am 6 Januar
waren es Vertreter vor einigen der
Bundesebene dieser Organisation wir
waren in Arizona bei einer Veranstaltung
wo sie Menschen beigebracht haben wie
man sich auf Kriege Konflikte aber auch
den Bürgerkrieg vorbereitet der kommen
könnte sie haben Ihnen gezeigt wie man
beispielsweise blutende Wunden stillt
oder wie man den Umgang mit Funkgeräten
erlernt oder wie man sich selber
Medikamente herstellt und ähnliches und
diese auf Keepers sind schwer bewaffnet
sind vor allen Dingen ehemalige Soldaten
ehemalige Polizisten teilweise auch noch
aktive Polizisten und bei dieser
Veranstaltung wurde ganz klar sich zwar
von der Gewalt am 6 Januar dist passiert
aber uns wurde in Interviews auch klar
gesagt dass man Verräter innerhalb der
republikanischen Partei vor Gericht
stellen müsse und dann hinrichten müsse
aufhängen
Köpfen enthaupten solche Äußerungen sind
da gefallen und da mit ist unter anderem
dieses Jenny gemeint die republikanische
Abgeordnete die ja jetzt die
stellvertretende Ausschussvorsitzende
ist hier im Untersuchungsausschuss aber
eben ihre Vorwahlen innerhalb der dem
republikanischen Partei verloren hat und
das zeigt im Grunde genommen dass so
eine Art Säuberungsaktion auch eine
politische Säuberungsaktion im Gange ist
die die sich gegen Donald Trump stellen
müssen damit rechnen dass sie bei den
Vorwahlen verlieren und das ist in
vielen Bundesstaaten in den letzten
Monaten tatsächlich der Fall gewesen und
hattest du während der Dreharbeiten für
deine Doku das Gefühl dass der dass der
Graben der Riss die Spaltung noch mal
tiefer geworden ist im Land
ja das hängt auch damit zusammen dass
ich sag mal die erstens die Fakten nicht
akzeptiert werden also es ist durch
Untersuchungsausschüsse unter anderem
auch einen Untersuchungsausschuss in
Michigan geführt von einem
republikanischen Senator mit dem wir uns
da getroffen haben admeck room heißt er
sehr eindeutig belegt dass es diesen
großen betrug eben nicht gegeben hat das
hat er auch in seinen Abschlussbericht
hineingeschrieben aber uns sind überall
Republikaner begegnet die das nicht
glauben die sind fest davon überzeugt
bei der Wahl wurde betrogen und bei der
nächsten Wahl würde dann wahrscheinlich
wieder betrogen werden wenn ihre
Kandidaten dabei unterliegen also da
wächst eine Wut und Entschlossenheit
heran die brandgefährlich ist und es
kommt eben eins dazu auch das haben wir
gesehen dass in diesem Bundesstaaten
eben Gouverneurs Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten antreten auch für
innenministerämter die nicht nur sagen
dass bei der Wahl betrogen wurde Karin
lake in Arizona beispielsweise tritt für
das Amt der Gouv an mit ihr konnten wir
auch sprechen sondern die uns dann auch
sagt Amerika ist keine Demokratie
sondern Amerika ist eine
konstitutionelle Republik und eine
Demokratie ist gefährlich weil sie ist
ermöglicht dass die Mehrheit Klammer auf
sie nennen es den Mob Klammer zu dass
die der Minderheit einfach mal alles auf
diktieren in allen Punkten Ihnen sagen
was Sie zu tun haben und darüber haben
wir dann mit den aufkkeepers auch mit
carry Lake diskutiert weil wenn man
hineinschaut in die Verfassung wenn man
in die Gesetze reinschaut in die Regeln
für die Wahl das sind alles
demokratische Regeln und wenn es hier
sagt man aussieht wie eine Ente
watschelt wie eine Ente und quakt wie
eine Ente dann ist es eine Ente also es
ist eine
konstitutionelle Demokratie wo die
konstitu die Verfassung quasi die
Menschen schützt vor im Grunde genommen
mehr als Entscheidungen die ihre
individuellen Rechte in irgendeiner
Weise schaden ihnen schaden könnte aber
das wird nicht akzeptiert von all diesen
Kandidaten auch von vielen dieser Wähler
die sind ja festen Überzeugung Amerika
ist keine Demokratie und das ist so eine
tiefgreifende
antagonistische Auffassung sage ich mal
dass mir kaum möglich scheint dass man
zwischen diesen Lagern irgendwie noch
wieder eine Versöhnung zumindest mal in
den nächsten Monaten herbeiführt zu
lange Trump und solange die trumpisten
noch diesen Einfluss auf die Bevölkerung
ausüben können und Manuel Falke fragt
sich auf Youtube ob die fehlende
gesellschaftliche Solidarität eben in
Form eines Sozialstaates der Grund für
Rechtsextremismus und Spaltung in den
USA ist
ja das kann man so und so sehen also
Amerika ist eigentlich bekannt dafür
dass ich sag mal man sich nicht vom
Staat aus eben für die Schwächeren in
der Gesellschaft engagiert sondern dass
das tatsächlich der Initiative der
Menschen überlassen wird und dass man
sieht wie sehr eben tatsächlich Menschen
in den USA über
Wohltätigkeitsorganisationen über
privates Engagement sich auch für
schwächere im Land engagieren aber es
wird tatsächlich ein Stück weit im
Grundsatz abgelehnt dass auch der Staat
da seine Aufgabe hat
den Menschen zu helfen wenn sie wirklich
in Not geraten und das führt aber
manchmal zu recht seltsamen Situationen
als wir bei in Arizona bei carry Lake
bei einer Wahlkampfveranstaltung waren
wo sie vom Podium herunter ich sag mal
vor recht reichen Leuten deren große
Fahrzeuge draußen vor der Tür standen in
einer reichen Gegend sagte wie wie
schlimm die doch alle dran sein durch
die Inflation und durch
ähm durch die Gesetze die in Washington
gemacht würden und gleichzeitig
gegenüber denen die als ärmste kommen
die auf der Flucht sind teilweise das
sind die Zuwanderer die über die Grenze
kommen tatsächlich ja auch
illegal über die Grenze kommen aber wenn
sie von denen spricht sie als Invasion
bezeichnen als Invasoren bezeichnet sie
sie als Kriminelle und damit natürlich
auch die Ärmsten innerhalb der
Gesellschaft trifft viele Latinos
beispielsweise in Arizona denen es
wirtschaftlich deutlich schlechter geht
als die Menschen die abends bei dieser
Wahlkampfveranstaltung waren also es ist
eine Doppelmoral am Werke und ganz
offenbar eine Bewegung im Land die
erheblich dazu beitragen wird dass es
eher in den Autoritarismus hier
weitergehen könnte in den nächsten
Jahren in den USA es sei denn bei der
zwischenwahl im November können die
Demokraten vielleicht doch die
Mehrheiten halten und auch dafür gibt es
ein zwei Gründe warum das passieren
könnte
es gibt noch eine Frage von Sven
Odendahl hätte Trump genug finanzielle
Mittel um jenseits der Demokraten und
Republikaner antreten zu können das gab
es ja nur selten aber ob das denkbar
wäre
ja das könnte er davor haben natürlich
auch die Republikaner Angst dann würden
sich aber die stimmen wahrscheinlich
splitten und am Ende würden die
Demokraten davon profitieren unterm
Strich aber wenn ich sagen darf ein Wort
noch tatsächlich zu diesen
Zwischenwahlen tatsächlich spielt eine
große Rolle für die Menschen im Land ob
Extremisten eine Chance haben an die
Macht zu kommen sowohl im Kongress in
Washington als auch in den Ämtern in den
Bundesstaaten das heißt es könnte dazu
führen dass die Demokraten am Ende mehr
Stimmen bekommen und auch die Diskussion
um das Abtreibungsrecht in den USA das
durch Gerichtsurteil ja gekippt worden
ist im Juni diesen Jahres führt dazu
dass Menschen mobilisiert werden und
zwar eben für die Demokraten da sind
nicht alles demokratische Wähler sondern
es sind auch unabhängige teilweise auch
Republikaner die bisher republikanisch
gewählt haben also es kann sein dass bei
der Wahl im November möglicherweise
Demokraten ihre Mehrheiten behalten das
wäre historisch denn das ist nach dem
zur zwischenwahl innerhalb der ersten
Amtszeit eines Präsidenten in den USA
bisher fast nie geschehen
und dazu kann man vielleicht den
Kommentar von Hunter auf Youtube noch
Vorlesen er schreibt ich hoffe echt dass
die USA es endlich schafft Trump zu
vergessen und wieder zu einer richtigen
Demokratie zurückkommen kann Emma ich
danke Dir ganz herzlich für Deine
Schilderungen deine Doku sehen wir am 2
November richtig
korrekt 22 Uhr sehr gut oder eben online
und bis dahin wirst Du uns weiter auf
dem laufenden halten vielen dank dir
tschüss
bitte schön tschüss ja und damit machen
wir Schluss für heute vielen Dank für
die Fragen und Kommentare und noch einen
schönen Abend bis dann tschüss
[Musik]